[Applaudissements]
attention c'est par un jour bonjour
c'est vrai c'est assez amusant c'est
pour une plainte se plaindre qu'on n'est
pas contente
on est sérieuse dites masculines au
porte bonheur de ses proches
bonjour les hommes ont fêté d'abord
toute la journée c'est du 30 avenue
durand d'informatique
c'est du shopping partie du jeu big ben
à la coquine
[Rires]
alors le braille est pas un regard a pas
eu notamment bon billon je me suis même
fait le maillot et la moustache un
torchon sont pas mignonne et les petites
gens à sebring à l'émeute et suzanne
fini coquine q les voir rester là dessus
je prends pas mieux
ah je reconnais christophe carrière
c'était tapé dans l'oeil mais là
non mais je vois que vous avez étudié
votre petit semoun regarder les petites
annonces et la journée c'était c'était
le rythme alors ça c'était bien
pardon trop de temps s'était trop
précipité le top pour moi c'est eux qui
ont gagné
non et non
ouais en deux non non je dirais en deux
kevin a